hmm
can i bring something up that i think is
really important or what's what's
crapping
so i want to bring something up like you
know some people are institutionalized
of course like you know i'm sure you
didn't you say you have a friend who's
like in jail for murder i was that
friend
i went and got a dui one time and i was
in jail for like
a solid 16 hours it's really weird
because mike is
because of that every time he's eating
oh he covers his food i hover over my
food it's
really weird it's really weird you know
i'll fight people over touching things
sometimes i walk in and he's making a
knife out of a toothbrush
you never want like even in the house
you just want to always be ready
do you always be ready yeah you don't
know when somebody's gonna try to jump
you on the way to the bathroom
there's like three bathrooms but [ __ ]
there's so many men just run away
all right thank you by the way johnny
arcade for this clip and also whenever i
don't feel safe i just go
guards
they're really going to kill you
i swear to god guys there's people that
i know that that have been through
prison that miss it
because the the real world the free
world is such a [ __ ] disaster now
there are prisons that are that are fun
for real
especially if you don't have a family
like if it's like a dude without a
family
and he gets a year i'm not talking state
pen but county or federal
you can have a good time you'd have a
good time in
county he's look he's not wrong about
like the bernie madoff types
yeah they're your father but like county
jails terry you know how many people are
terrible
they're not getting their suboxone and
they're throwing up everywhere and
there's just piss everywhere like it's
not
night it's not fun betty spaghetti says
county is the worst
i felt like when i went to jail i felt
like um
uh lewis winthrop winthorpe from uh
trading places oh yeah it was just like
those men tried to have sex with me
it was just everything was outrageous
this is outrageous
you're not getting the proper medical
care here
um you know you make a lot of buddies in
there as long as you're not with like
the animal animals like the people like
yo i got crunk i got that crunk
so the animals you mean like the blacks
because that's what he's
right and i got that crunk what does
that mean
no i mean i'm i don't unders first of
all when owen is talking about prison
like he's been
like he was instant you weren't like i
got mad friends that are like
institutionalized hey owen as roy said i
actually have
not one but i have two friends actually
i have three friends
in jail for murder-related charges all
right one of them's going to get the
goddamn needle
in broward uh the other one
was like a kind of an inselly kind of
mgtow guy
that went started dating a girl and he
went crazy and he shot like some dude in
the back over
uh and he's got attempted murder up in
duval county
and then i was like i dude i have
friends that are legit trust me nobody
like even the people that are
institutionalized like
god owen doesn't even explain that
properly
institutionalized is not hey i love jail
i want to go back to jail
institutionalized is when you've spent
so much time
in jail that you can't help but think
like a criminal piece of [ __ ]
so everything is a criminal act so you
always end up going back to
there's nobody i know even people that
are used to jail
who are going back to jail that are like
anything they're saying anything other
than
damn i gotta go back to jail nobody
wants to go to jail
and the other thing is is that because
you even said you know like where bernie
madoff's at
but even still it's it's it's all
comparable even the stuff like that
yes they're still not free but yeah the
jail the look the jail that bernie made
office in shore it's it's not
[ __ ] federal pound you're in the ass
jail like [ __ ] office spaces
but it's the same one like manafort's in
yeah yeah
but bernie madoff would rather be in his
penthouse in new york
than be hanging out with a bunch of
dudes at the yard you know what i mean
like
nobody when the other option is being
free
most people are going to pick free i
just love to the fact that he goes
yeah not like these real animals that
are like what's up dog
i'm very obviously an african american i
play it i guess so omo and benjamin and
i think african americans are animals
dog
that's what he just did i got crunk
i got that cronk if you're just with
people that were like in a gang or help
someone get rid of a bomb
benjamin just came just short of saying
ooga-booga
like i mean am i wrong very close like
he was basically
you know guys there are animals in jail
that are like
yo what up i'm a black dude i'm very
obviously using african-american
vernacular
google book like that's what he's doing
and you're going
what are you talking about like i've
been to jail and you know what
if you're dealing with a black guy or a
white guy again i didn't go to state
prison i didn't go to a
federal palmy in the ass president i
went to county and in county
you have just as many just the same odds
as meeting a cool black dude
as you do a cool white guy and you have
just as good odds of meeting a really
[ __ ] human being black guy and a really
[ __ ] human being white guy
it's just luck of the draw you know what
i mean
he's acting he literally went from
animal to black guy immediately
i lo i love the i love i sorry i
sometimes like pointing out stuff in the
chat
[ __ ] shuckelberg are you guys like
some anti-racist
yeah that's what it is so we um it's
also like he could have easily said like
uh
you know real animals in jail like you
see you know you get assigned to a cell
and the guy next to you is like yeah man
i mean
you know i [ __ ] my sister but you know
what i mean it was like she was 17.
so i mean legally in the stadium like
jesus that would be an animal in jail
and you go jesus christ dude yeah
something like that um by the way i just
can i can i
answer the dude that just said that sure
[ __ ] shackleberg
hey dude cool youtube name
i get it like jews right yeah he owned
them christ
like it's just you really own them like
literally some of you people have not
uh uh adjusted or adapted your [ __ ]
game plan or your
they're still acting like it's 2015.
it's weird and it's like
you're gonna come in here and piss on
our [ __ ] [ __ ] are you kidding me
all right or help someone get rid of a
body or something like that
um guys i mean have you been to a
boardroom of any corporation it's the
same [ __ ] it's just
mergers you know you know what mike you
know what's a really good show
you could tell he's not getting paid
where he's making a phone call during it
he's making a phone call he does this
all the time he's probably calling his
wife
and telling her to bring him something
acquisitions or murders
and executions oh american psycho
americans that was an american psycho
reference yeah
it's the same thing no i mean it's not i
mean you know something like that
some people work in offices and no it's
different some people
put uh tires around people's necks and
fill them with gasoline and set them on
fire it's a totally defender
even state yeah i've heard horror
stories about state but
there's probably some state pens that
are pretty fun
oh only eating [ __ ] slop food every day
sleeping in a a hot cell how is any of
that
fun he's a [ __ ] and he doesn't even
pretend to not be immortal no he's
really leaning into the [ __ ] thing huh
he's just right yeah he just is
yeah he sounds like i just started
talking about nuclear physics
right uh you could actually eat
plutonium but without even so much as
glancing at a wikipedia yeah
just go right into it guys i know a lot
about nuclear physics
when you go into space vacuum becomes a
liquid
and you travel through that's why things
are slower in space because it's a
liquid
people would go dude you don't know
obviously know anything
you're just thinking of the next word
and stringing words together
you could survive in space with scuba
gear it's like nobody that cannot be
proven
can you imagine just just the snorkeling
immediately die hands are pretty fine
you know it's it's if you respect
hierarchy that's why
that's why uh uh [ __ ] [ __ ] and
picking up i wanted another kombucha you
know that's what he's thinking
you know yeah he can't control that
see and then oh my god could you imagine
she doesn't pick up the phone so he
screams at her
can i ask you something right either you
or your wife
it wouldn't matter who's being the owen
and who's not in this situation with the
other one
at all reactories no that i'd be i would
be
livid
calling from outside and then going hey
what the [ __ ] are you doing you [ __ ]
lunatic just come and talk to me like a
[ __ ]
normal person oh he's [ __ ] crazy
right like that oh my oh
bro there's cert i know he's done far
more obnoxious thing he's doxxed
of course he's frightened but like there
are etiquette thing
because i'm an obnoxious dude and i have
to check that somebody he's an obnoxious
dude sometimes
and has to check it but like there are
things that people do where it's so
insane and obnoxious that you almost are
tolerated because you're like maybe this
person's clearly it's a bit then there's
things that's just
etiquette and you're like bro do you
just come in with muddy shoes all over
my [ __ ] floor
right like these things where people you
should always
i don't know man it's just or like it's
like it's like coming over somebody
comes over for a party in your house
knocks in an entire tray of burgers and
hot dogs over onto the ground
and it just leaks doesn't say sorry just
leaves and you go
like at least look no no not even just
leaves
denies doing it when you clearly saw
them do it that wasn't me
it wasn't me man maybe you need to get
your [ __ ] house in order
maybe you should have wobbly tables and
you're like you know dude i'm good
i'm going to kill you in this house i
have a pool that i will william shatner
wife
[ __ ] yeah i have a pool in this house
you have alcohol in your system i can
drown you convincingly yes
get out of here they will do a
toxicology report and go he must be
driving drinking
yeah don't drink and swim
that's why uh uh hey love
i can't i can't i'm sorry it's so funny
if i tried that somebody would have
thrown a bottle at me in this household
oh [ __ ] yellow what's wrong with you
we look at a civilized society you can't
do that
that's why our boxes hierarchy talks are
so important
i did yeah actually i did yell at the
neighbors last night while you guys were
out oh really yeah
for what what they have firework show
again last night like 9 30 tonight
at 9 30 there was fire what were they
just popping them off
yeah but not like a couple because you
know it's fourth of july coming up
just a few everybody likes to do it yeah
it was like
very loud powerful one got it goes off
in the sky and it was
every like four to five minutes oh for
about 20 minutes straight and by the
fourth one i was outside smoking
and one went off and i just yelled knock
it off really loud
did they knock it off and then it
stopped good it was actually very funny
and because you know the poor dogs
running around losing their [ __ ]
minds yeah and all right again one or
two you tested them out for fun but like
you're prolonging the dog's misery by
doing it every [ __ ] 10 minutes
and then it takes like about an hour for
the dog to get over the ptsd
yeah by the fourth one i was just like
knock it off you damn
kids and then it just it got quiet it's
like if you
the people that get all [ __ ] up in
prison are the ones that just walk into
a hierarchy
just like hey everybody my name's gary
and i like to draw on my penis
nobody in the history of prisons
has ever done that in the history of
prisons how funny would it be if
somebody has whatever whatever that's
just a regular joke in jail
we're the wrong ones oh you're right
i've drawn smiley faces
hey bro hey
hey i drew sad face that he said
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
everybody's just everybody's just
whipping each other with towels and
having a fun time in jail yeah it's
super funny who's a family guy that said
yeah
he saw it's summer camp it's summer camp
he saw the family guy episode
where they were having when they did the
choreographed song and dance routine and
whipped each other with towels and he
went that's jail
that's what it is and i like to draw on
my penis
you know if you know who the alphas are
who the bravos are who the generals are
the lieutenants who the deltas are
you know who the gamma [ __ ] are can i
can you pause i'm sorry somebody in the
chat saying you're taking this out of
context
this is owen benjamin so please put this
by all
means provide me with the context sir
no yeah please let me know the context
is where prisons are awesome that's like
you know when you go to like new york
city and there's always like some
schizophrenic guy at every subway
station that's just sitting there going
like
[ __ ] it's it's like it's always it's
always a schizophrenic
black guy who's dropping hard and bombs
you know what i mean like one of those
weird situations where you go
you keep hearing the n word over and
over again and you look but it's
actually a black dude yelling it because
they're just crazy and you're like
what the [ __ ] is that right you're like
the person going yeah but you don't
understand the context
you're like he's a schizophrenic black
guy yelling n word at white people and
asians in a subway
there's no context this is my favorite i
i love
i love comparing comparing and
contrasting stuff from yesterday
yesterday was like you guys never talk
about oh and today don't you have any
content that doesn't revolve around owen
you don't wait no matter what you do you
know it's weird right because everybody
keeps telling us what [ __ ] when
you're [ __ ]
whatever and it's like i'm starting to
realize that maybe
some of you guys are the miserable
pricks it may be your projecting yeah
seriously
and we did a whole hour and 20 minutes
of the show what are you talking about
yeah
who the omegas are the ones you don't
you stay away from the sigmas that just
kind of do their own thing these are all
made up vox day things owen they're not
real
they're not real and by the way your
buddy vox they went on infowars the same
infowars that you hate and call alex
jones a show
it's [ __ ] great jail is a low-end
country club yeah
you know there's no women nope oh j only
the jews are there
usually house arrest
why would you be on house arrest in
prison
very very weird he doesn't understand
things man you know
that it's getting worse he doesn't
understand it's getting worse and he's
gonna [ __ ] been lost somebody and
we're gonna get blamed
you think so yeah i don't know those two
were picking on him
oh so i mean and no no no i don't ever
feel bad about that because he [ __ ]
owen picks on everybody everybody that
he's used to be his friend he wrongs him
and he shits on him he's done it to alex
he's [ __ ] does it does it to [ __ ]
rogan
to ben shapiro he does it to everybody
so please
don't act like no i don't want anybody
acting like owen is his innocent victim
he shits on everybody he doesn't like to
be picked on